the tensor flow graph is a source of
pride performance and frustration among
users how can we keep the pride and
performance but without the frustration
stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're gonna check
out how to smooth over some of those
pain points that exist in using the
tensor flow graph tensor flow has been
long associated with the computational
graph after all the library is all about
tensors that flow through a graph yet
this can be a source of great
frustration for folks who are just
starting out this is mostly because
everything is part of the graph and I
mean everything from the numbers that
are used to represent your models to the
operations themselves everything is part
of the graph this can lead to various
difficulties when it comes time to say
debug your tensor flow code since the
development model can kind of feel like
write everything perfectly and then run
it you wrote it all perfectly right of
course programming should not operate
like this it would be great to be able
to iterate on things see partial results
and peer into the graph to be able to
print out more meaningful outputs than
just tensor NAT Molesey row shape to 2d
type float32 what does that mean
but how can you ignore the deferred
execution process of the graph this is
the goal of eager mode tensor flow will
eagerly execute your operations thus
allowing you to see the results right as
you're working rather than waiting until
everything is coded up and connected
before you can see if anything is done
right let's take a look at this basic
example where I'm multiplying some
numbers together when we haven't yet
enabled eager mode things work the way
we are used to printing out a tensor
flow variable give some informational
text about the operation and the
expected dimensions but to actually
execute that node
we'll need to do a bit more boilerplate
code by wrapping it in a session and
then running that session to pull out
the values this is just way too much
code to just try to look at some numbers
now let's try that same code but will
enable eager mode by adding TF dot
enable eager execution as the very first
thing that is run after import
tensorflow and we'll look at what
happens the printed results they show
exactly the value of the matrix
multiplication that's what's great about
eager mode it enables you to use
tensorflow more efficiently without
losing prior functionality or the
features that you're used to so much of
software development lives in the trial
and error process in running some code
seeing what errors you get back and
changing that code so the sooner you can
test the code and see the errors the
more efficient and effective you can be
thanks for watching this episode of
cloudy I adventures and if you enjoyed
it please like it and subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right when they
come out we're now try out Eco mode see
if it's right for you